hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the Mr dodgy Invitational it is the
long-awaited clash between Magnus
Crossing and Daniel dubov and much like
the match between Croatia and Belgium
today in football in the world Football
Championship uh it did not go the way I
thought it would go so I'm not gonna
spoil it right away but I will spoil it
soon uh so I I really had to choose
which game to show as you guys were
really requesting a game from this match
uh but I'm sure you guys are aware of
what I'm talking about so let's dive
straight into it Magnus has the white
pieces uh and he opens with Pawn to E4
like all of the games in the Mr Dodge
Invitational this is uh five plus zero
seconds increment so this is the most
extreme time format in uh over the board
chess of course online chess there are
more extreme formats but uh when we're
talking over the board chess five plus
zero is the norm so see five dubo goes
for the Sicilian Defense Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and now Bishop to B5 Magnus
goes for the Nish medino rossolimo
attack uh sorry about that and uh here
there are some very popular replies for
black like G6 this is the most played
idea you E6 and D6 these are the like
top two and top three Knight to F6 this
is also a fine move but the do-over goes
for Pawn to E5 and this is uh the 10th
most uh popular uh continuation uh and a
very tricky one uh for for whites to
handle if you don't know what's
happening of course the capturing and C6
runs into the pretty much the same thing
as uh similar structures do if D
captures Knight captures an E5 then
Queen D4 attacks the pawn and the Knight
and you have to move the Knight to lose
the E4 Pawn with the check and the black
equalizes at the least
so after E5 we have Castles by Magnus uh
of course he knows this stuff Knight gt7
and now Rook to E1 we have G6 by dubov
uh D3 and now Bishop to G7 and here we
have Bishop to G5 there is a game uh
from uh
1984 between ratmir kholmov and Victor
kuprechik where uh Knight the C3 was
played that game ended in a draw but
here uh with Bishop to G5 by Magnus and
it is now already as of move 7 that we
have a completely new game uh so dubo
goes for H6 and interestingly Magnus
gives up the bishop pair Bishop captures
an E7 Knight captures and now Knight to
C3 now Magnus with full control over
that D5 Square we have castles and the
bishop the C4 even more control over the
D5 Square D6 and now Knight to D5 now if
Knight captures Bishop captures then
Magnus is forever the owner of the D5
Square so here Knight the C6 we have C3
3 controlling this Knight also preparing
a for B for d for all of the uh famous
strikes with King to H7 and now Pawn to
A4 with Bishop to E6 and now Pawn to H3
just throwing in some useful moves with
rooked the C8 and now Knight the E3 uh
Bishop to D7 and now Bishop to D5 by
Magnus we have Queen to E7 and now Pawn
to A5 grabbing more space preparing A6
uh Rook the B8 and now Queen to D2
developing the queen connecting Rooks
wave Knight to d8 and now Bishop back
the C4 preparing Knight to D5 as the
queen is on E7 so the Knight is very
well suited on D5
uh Knight the six by dubov and Knight
the D5 attacking the black queen queen
to d8 and now Pawn to B4 by Magnus as
one usually uh should play this so C
captures on b4c captures and now Pawn to
F5 and this is a well pretty pretty
standard position why it has more
control in the center he has a beautiful
Knight and D5 black has more Pawns in
the center and the black has a weak D6
Pawn white has a weak D3 Pawn so it's a
bit of a trade-off both players have two
two pawns on the queen side uh nothing
uh spectacular Happening Here white
should always be a little bit better but
nothing spectacular so Queen to E3
Magnus is just saying I'm not interested
in captors I'm not interested in F4 I'm
just gonna go after the A7 Pawn it's
undefended so how do you defend this and
okay Duba was Rook to C8 he goes uh uh
well not after the bishop but the Rook
is now very well placed here point is if
you go for Queen captures on A7 then
look at this F captures on e4 Rook
counters and The Rook captures an F3
this was dubov's idea and now if Magnus
captures then Knights the G5 attacks the
h31 attacks the F3 Pawn attacks The Rook
now the bishop is attacking H3 the queen
will be able to enter the game it's a
very very tricky position and unless
Magnus finds the only move that gives
him Advantage Queen to E3 dubo is
already uh well very much equalized even
Queen D3 it's not all that spectacular
for white it's just maybe a little bit
better
uh but okay after Rook the C8 Rook ate
the C1 Magnus doesn't go for the pawn
and now Knight the D4 here we have
Knight camp for Sunday for and uh what
what would you play here as black it's a
very interesting position where only one
move doesn't uh lose uh lose on uh by
force uh for black so of course uh as as
soon as I said this you know the D
Capital Sun D4 is not the move you
should play and you find Ponte F4 which
is a move dubo did not find you have to
find Ponte F4 and only after the queen
moves you play Pawn captures because now
uh you can't really capture uh the DF
for Pawn if Knight captures an F4 then
Queen to G5 already you allow uh black
the really uh develop and white will
struggle here so after Knight captures
on D4 we have e captures on the for Doom
of immediately captures it but now he
hands over the G3 Square to Magnus
Magnus plays Queen to G3 and now how do
do you defend it's not easy and it's
very hard to find the move for black
Rook to E8 is pretty much the only move
you can play but after Bishop to E5 now
it's all Magnus from here you're
attacking the queen and of course you're
you're hoping for the queen to move so
you can finally push this F4 before that
you couldn't do that the Knight and the
queen cover F4 but after uh Magnus plays
F4 there's just nothing for duboff to do
uh Bishop to G7 was played now e
characters on F5 and now Magnus with
full control over the E7 Square Bishop
captures an F5 Rook to E7 and now King
th8 tan pinning so the bishop can move
Rook C to E1 doubling up on the E file
and pawn to B5 now here hoping for
Bishop captures uh so you can at least
get the Rook into the attack but Magnus
just plays eight captures on B6 Alpha
song eight captors and now Queen to F2
uh so what's the idea here uh the idea
is that dubov is uh still without a move
he plays B5 he wants to activate his
pieces somehow but now Magnus can pretty
much do anything he can choose how he
wants to win this he chooses not a rook
capture Sun G7 and it's such a fine way
to end the game King captures and now
Queen captures and D4 with check we have
King to G8 with King th7 you still
prolong the game a little bit uh there's
Queen to A7 check and then it's it then
Rook to E7 and it's still on defendable
but here after King to G8 it's actually
a a force made in six and there's
nothing you can do about it Knight to F6
check was played King the h8 and now we
reach this uh wonderful position from
the thumbnail where it's forced
Checkmate in five for white so feel free
to pause the video and try to find this
forcing line uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the
inevitable mate in 5 and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Knight to H5 check that's the
discovery that you have to play and now
it's made in five only if black presents
the uh most optimal defense which is
Rook to F6 and then Rook to E8 with
check a nice sacrifice to get the queen
away from the defense of the Rook on F6
and after Queen captures just Queen
captures and F6 with check King to H7
and this will now be Checkmate Queen G7
is Checkmate but dubo said all right I'm
not interested in this year this is
spectacular stuff I'm just gonna give
you mating one he played King to H7 and
the Magnus now of course delivered at
Queen to G7 Checkmate and that is it
that's it for this game and it basically
all came down to this moment where dubov
could have defended but after Knight
captures on D4 he shouldn't have
automatically recaptured he should have
advanced against this Pawn to F4 and
only after the queen moves now captures
and now this is impossible because like
we said you give black too much counter
play uh that was the only way to play
but after he gave Magnus this uh one one
move just captures and then Queen to G3
there was pretty much no saving game
from there and now I will spoil the
result I know I said I I'm gonna spoil
it a bit sooner but uh I decided not to
uh Magnus actually won the match won the
finals of the Mr dodgy Invitational 3.0
without losing a single game I think it
was the same score uh he had in the
previous match uh I'm gonna check I
don't want to trick you guys but I'm
pretty sure of it uh yeah he he wanted
uh oh yeah very very convincingly seven
to one so seven to one that is
absolutely spectacular uh just
completely crushing it uh I think yeah
it's the same score he he had against
seminal seven in the in the semi-finals
but between in dubov in the finals with
a score of seven to one that's six wins
and two draws absolutely spectacular
like like I said I thought we would see
more from dubov uh he I mean he played
absolutely spectacular chess he crushed
uh grishock in the in the finals okay
not not in terms of of score uh but in
terms of uh I mean beauty of Play It Was
it was truly a spectacular match and I
thought we would see more here against
Magnus but uh Magnus now returned to
Europe he had a good night's sleep and
he said that ever since he returned uh
he's been playing good chess and he has
been Unstoppable uh in the entire Mr
dodgy Invitational knockout he lost only
only three games to shivchenko everyone
else he he crushed without losing a
single game so uh truly a spectacular
feat from Agnes and here is a uh not a
cross table but here is uh what tari
Swenson uh posted on Twitter this is
everything uh Magnus won so far and uh
to to all of this you now add the the
prestigious Mr dodgy Invitational so
Magnus won five times uh worldshire
championship match uh five times World
Blitz Championship three times the world
rapid Championship he won uh was this
eighth time first place in uh in Vikings
five times in Stavanger uh four times in
London uh four times in Champion or four
times in St Louis two times in green K
two times in town Memorial uh two times
in Nanjing uh two three times he won the
Champions Chester and two times he won
the grand Chester and now to all of this
you add the Mr dodgy Invitational and
now of course the question uh can
finally be asked is a Magnus crossing
the goat is he the greatest of all times
uh we're gonna be asking that for as
long as Magnus Carlsen remains active as
a chess player but I'm sure you guys
already have made up your mind because
those who who consider him the greatest
uh consider him the greatest and those
who don't it's a very unlikely that they
will change their mind but yeah I mean
if you have anything more to add to what
Taria posted here feel free to do so in
the in the comment section below uh but
yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it uh all of the all of the
games uh in the entire match Magnus just
crushed it dubov said that okay there
was one turning point in the match where
he had an end game maybe he could have
played a little bit better in that match
which took a different turn but it
didn't and Magnus just completely
crushed it
congratulations to Magnus on winning
this most prestigious event I would also
like to thank Jerry driver born a smack
Jung Yang Stefan trifonovich and Andre
Shrader for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else is
happening in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day